blood may be thicker than water but
apparently it's not thicker than
kool-aid i don't think she's ever had
kool-aid before
all right you know some beliefs are easy
to debunk
for example this was definitely not cat
tim
out at a bar last night
[Applause]
and on a work night we are also told by
the media that diversity is the single
most
important issue right now at work and at
school they all agree on this
no diversity there it's group think
without the think part
but if earnest white liberals believe
that too many white people are in
undeserved jobs
why aren't they resigning to make room
for non-white people
i'll give the viewers at home 10 minutes
to stop laughing
but if the woke agree that white
students or employees need to abdicate
their leadership roles
shouldn't they lead by example take cnn
surely in a nation of more than 300
million there must be a better jeff
zucker out there
a black one the white one is terrible at
his job
yet there he sits all entitled but if
you ask that question
it's guaranteed not a single left-wing
caucasian will take you up on it
they want you to put your job on the
market not theirs they love to virtue
signal
because it's non-action that replaces
real action
you also see this in the hilariously
hypocritical world of climate change
as campus reform points out gen z and
millennials the kids we send to college
to make them unlikable
and unemployable are the most likely to
get involved in climate activism
and they talk a good game they'll tell
you to use
less fuel and eat less meat which makes
me think they're the ones responsible
for the last two hackings
but ask them to practice what they
preach and they collapse faster than a
thriving economy under joe biden
dare them to back up their words with
actions and they fold faster than a
hammock
holding brian stelter in his jumbo bag
of deep fried doughnut holes
chris cuomo feeds them into his mouth
like grapes
reporter foley a folly jacobson sorry
visited georgetown university and talked
to students to see how
much they were willing to do for the
planet and of course everyone agreed how
crucial it was to fight climate change
how important is climate change to you
and combating it fighting against it
well climate change is like everything
when you live you need like to have
a clear air and like a clear environment
i think it's really important because
the climate is something that we live in
and we
thrive on so it's something we need to
protect i mean it directly affects us
so and everything around us so i think
yeah i don't think people have been
doing enough for it
very important and very pressing and it
should be talked about more i agree it's
very important
and should be taken more seriously and
it upsets me i agree with what they said
and then it upsets me that it's been
politicized do you think we should be
doing everything in our power as
individuals to try and combat it
yeah obviously yeah like when you see
like it's very important so why not
like this shouldn't be even a question
it'll
directly affect us so we should be doing
everything we can
barton released a plan for climate
change trying to combat the crisis would
you support a plan like that
yes generally would follow it if it did
things correctly
yes i actually he mentioned that in his
um
speech of congress correct yeah
definitely since it's such a
such a big issue right now yeah i would
definitely support any plan to try and
help it
yes how thoughtful our future is in safe
hands
if only they could pronounce the first t
in important are t's
bad for the environment it's important
to me
important but what happens when you ask
them to sign a pledge
vowing to actually do their part what do
you think
do you guys vow to stop all personal air
travel so never use an airplane
especially international travel do you
guys pledge to eat a cold dinner three
times a week to decrease how many times
you use your stove
because that creates carbon emissions
and would you guys commit to living
somewhere where you can only use
a bike so you would have to sell your
car you would have to bike to work into
school every single day
if you guys vow to do all three of these
things you guys can sign the pledge
but if you guys don't i'm sorry we have
to go
they fled like they were being chased by
charlie rose in an open robe with a jar
of vick's vapor rub
[Laughter]
let's hear more so you would never fly a
plane ever again
i mean that that that one could be
a little bit difficult would you be
willing to do all three of these things
you know never travel on an airplane
again and never use a car
eat cold dinners in an effort to combat
climate change
yes for a given amount of time
but for the rest of your life probably
not i
travel a lot so it's going to be
difficult how's like you know like where
would i like go
how would i get around you know i'll be
eating cold dinner three times a week
to decrease the times of stuff
what about the other ones uh
maybe not i definitely can vow to do the
first one however i don't know about the
second
because it'd be difficult finding
meals that don't require cooking wait he
says
it would be difficult to find edible
uncooked food
apparently he's never heard of this
thing called an apple
[Laughter]
that's what's keeping him from saving
the planet his fear of a cold hot pocket
finally looking at this plan a lot of
politicians are pushing for this
obviously president biden created it
do you think they're going to be the
ones to stop their plane travel and to
stop using cars or do you think they're
going to continue to do the same thing
while they ask other americans to stop i
think they're going to continue doing
the same thing
it's annoying and rude because if
they're wanting to us
to stop why don't they stop to it's not
fair that's
less selfishness for me again like if
they're going to expect us to do it
then expect everyone to do it it seems
like they're flying all over so
i would say it's pretty hypogriddle
hypocritical for them to say that all
americans should stop when they're not
that vocal fry it's
almost like they just learned something
so it's easy to poke fun of young minds
who endorse crap that they really
haven't thought through
which is why we do it it's friday
and it's also why god made democrats
they never have second thoughts because
it's hard enough coming up with the
first one
and it's not entirely the kid's fault
schools used to teach people how to
think
now they teach them how to feel and
especially to feel bad
about the planet about america about
their past as an oppressor
i wonder what the angry white male has
to say
[Music]
people ask me if i believe in the
concept of privilege you bet i do
was i born with a set of advantages yes
i was
do i owe everything i've ever
accomplished to those advantages i do
my privilege being born in the usa
[Music]
he's whiter than eating marshmallows at
brooks brothers
so now the losers and media are trying
to convince us to eat insects to save
the planet
we're gonna have to start paying extra
for that fly in your soup
cnn forced one anchor to wolf down a
cicada on live tv
it was embarrassing but some of her best
work
i'm talking about the cicada i wonder
what's cooking on cnn now
how many is up for you like 900 this is
such an
easy sack suffice to make for saving the
environment totally i would eat them for
another 17 years if it meant saving the
planet when did cnn become the food
network
next up wolf blitzer shares his recipe
for cockroach casserole with a graham
cracker crust
research shows that what's being taught
about climate change is creating
eco anxiety among kids turning happy
kids into terrified basket cases
of course this is their poster child
as if acne and snapchat and teachers
unions aren't enough trouble kids now
have to shoulder the coming apocalypse
and you know what some teachers suggest
to help to expand the climate emergency
curriculum
yes whatever is making these kids sick
should be mandatory
for everyone how is this not bullying
that's the world we live in
now the planet is sick but it's not from
climate change it's sick
from some very lonely media inspired
leftists who want to make your life as
miserable and as useless as theirs can
you blame them
well yes yes you can
[Applause]
he's got more great views than a house
in malibu
sirius xm radio sunny
he thinks mayonnaise is too spicy hosted
the quiz show on fox station
he's as uncomfortable as a middle seat
in coach between a couple arguing about
sex
comedian joe becky
and she always kills on stage because
she poisoned all your drinks
foxes contributor captive
sonny is college worth it i didn't go so
i wouldn't know
you didn't go no i didn't um i i ended
up getting sick my high school year
okay and so i had spent the entire year
trying to recuperate and get my body
back together and by time it was over i
was in the streets
wow and you didn't miss it no not a bit
and when i had my daughter i decided hey
you better learn something so you can
teach this little one
but that kind of goes to talking about
all of this because
you blamed the school for it yeah the
school didn't do this right they started
with us with captain planet
like back then if you wanted to be like
one of the cool ones you wanted to be a
planeteers
right they gave you they started us very
very young
being petrified that the world was just
going to disappear if we didn't do
everything within our power to um
to combat climate change but the funny
thing was
none of us wanted to be planeteers yeah
no all of us wanted to go to scrooge
mcduck's uh
tower and jump into the money bit no
matter how many times
you try to push the indoctrination when
we
actually get to make the choice we're
always going to choose to jump in the
money bit
just that that is my um how i can give
people comfort
as long as you give capitalism as an
option
it will naturally win out it is so true
it is so true
instead what what they're doing though
is they're they're pushing these people
in the woke lane
not the capitalist lane but sooner or
later they got to realize it by the way
to your point
the person who created captain planet
also created cnn
ted turner yep right wow you didn't have
that i didn't know that
tom there's a lot
we think that they're trying to
entertain they are not trying to
entertain they are
purposely indoctrinating and they've
been doing it for decades
you know tom as a racist you might must
find this
[Laughter]
i do greg and i think that
well obviously the environment is not
only important it's also
it's also patriotic greg
but the i was impressed by some of the
ironclad
logic of these students i loved that
girl's
reason for not giving up travel was
i travel a lot yes i mean you can't
argue
with that no you can't she travels a lot
yeah you know i think that the
environmental movement
shares a lot with what happened this
year with the uh you know
the the hysteria over the environment
and the hysteria over covid the same
people
used the same tactics to scare people i
think you're off base
i am not off baseball i am so on base oh
you're
dead you can't get me it's real a
problem
greg i get oppressed when two white men
start yelling calm down
calm down you should not shame on you
for saying covet is real
when i'm making a great point when of
course it's real greg but the tactics
that these totalitarians are using yeah
okay
shut down the shutdown of the economy
right see
the environmentalists really they never
really cared about the planet what they
care about is controlling
economies okay because it's angry
because it's leftism
and the same people who are trying to
turn us into a health state what they
did is they want to shut down economies
but in the bargain
they also want to control our individual
health so they're using the same
techniques i'm not off base i'm right
there on base
well you know it's interesting i'm going
to edit all of that out of this show and
replace it with little poodles
because you like poodles i love poodles
and you know what i like
i like to pet poodles while i'm eating
marshmallows in brooks brothers
yes is your poodle wearing a little
raincoat yes because that would be very
white of you yeah
all right all right joe are you
terrified of the
a climate apocalypse are you more scared
of these kids i i'm
not terrified no i'll tell you why ted
turner
created captain planet but he also
farmed bison
and that brings me to my point being a
hypocrite is awesome
i've been a hypocrite for some time and
i'll tell you what it's way better than
not being a hypocrite
you can do things like cancel the
keystone pipeline here
and support the nord stream pipeline in
europe yes you can do things like
say that climate change is the most
important thing out there
and then have jeff bezos fly you a
t-shirt to your house
that is like the consequences of the
explosion of like
delivery from amazon we haven't even
quantified but i order
albums i i and i don't even think about
it but they show up here every day like
from a magic album fairy jeff bezos he's
a big
climate change advocate but he just
bought a 500 foot yacht which is so big
it's more like a cruise ship for one
that's a man who just wants to be alone
how important
important yeah important is it to learn
how to say important
not at all i say it important and i am i
am a
uh a shining beacon of success yes
some might say role model many people
look up to me yes that's true
i hope not uh yeah i i don't think that
it is i think it's
i'm so glad you you know said something
about the hypocrisy both with the
climate change stuff and also
all the white people who say we need
more people of color
in these positions but they stay in
their positions
right i'm not sure it's because you know
chris cuomo for example
is just doing unparalleled work for the
black community
that is so important that nobody else
could ever
possibly do it and i i think where a lot
of this comes from
is because i don't know if they think
about it that far they just know they
need to say it
right so that they can actually stay in
that position
and not be canceled yeah and how easy is
it to do that and i think the one way
where it was like covid was i think
a lot of people didn't want it to stop
because that's the easiest virtue signal
of all
yes you have you're a better person than
everyone else because you stay home and
do nothing
yeah wear masks that's hard to give up
yeah why'd you agree with cap but not me
greg see what you're doing there you're
crazy yeah you are a crazy psychopath
tom
i know it i'm moderately hinged yes
that is really important i learned a lot